CONFIRMATIONS FOR CIA DIRECTOR.
JOHN BRENNAN AND GINA HASPEL.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
LET'S TAKE A TRIP BACK TO 2013
WHEN DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED WHAT THEY NOW OPPOSE.
ON MARCH 7 OF THAT YEAR, THE
SENATE HAD CONFIRMED OBAMA CIA
DIRECTOR NOMINEE JOHN BRENNAN.
NOW BEAR IN MIND, HE WAS
PREVIOUSLY DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL COUNTERTERRORISM CENTER
AND REPORTEDLY A SUPPORTER OF
ENHANCED INTERROGATION.
13 REPUBLICANS WERE AMONG THE 63
SENATORS WHO VOTED TO CONFIRM
BRENNAN, INCLUDING SENATORS
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
JOHN McCAIN.
JUST TWO DEMOCRATS VOTED AGAINST
THE NOMINEE, PAT LEAHY AND JEFF
MERKLEY ALONG WITH INDEPENDENT
BERNIE SANDERS.
NOW, THE ISSUE OF BRENNAN'S
INVOLVEMENT IN THE ENHANCED
INTERROGATION IN THAT WHOLE
PROGRAM DIDN'T CONCERN THE
DEMOCRATS ON THE SENATE INTEL
COMMITTEE BACK THEN.
OF THE 50 DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED TO
CONFIRM BRENNAN IN 2013, 36 ARE
STILL IN OFFICE.
DURING BRENNAN'S CONFIRMATION
HEARING IN FEBRUARY OF 2013,
WEAPONIZED DRONES WERE THE BIG
ISSUE.
THIS IS HOW THE QUESTION OF
WATERBOARDING WAS ADDRESSED.
>> WHAT STEPS DID YOU TAKE TO
STOP CIA FROM MOVING TO THESE
TECHNIQUES YOU NOW SAY YOU FOUND
OBJECTIONABLE AT THE TIME?
>> I DID NOT TAKE STEPS TO STOP
THE CIA'S USE OF THOSE
TECHNIQUES.
I WAS NOT IN THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND OF THAT PROGRAM.
I'VE EXPRESSED MY PERSONAL
OBJECTIONS AND USED TO AGENCY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT CERTAIN OF
THOSE EIT'S SUCH AS
WATERBOARDING, AND OTHERS WHERE
I PROFESS MY PERSONAL OBJECTIONS
TO IT BUT I DID NOT TRY TO
STOP IT BECAUSE IT WAS, YOU
KNOW, SOMETHING THAT WAS BEING
DONE IN A DIFFERENT PART OF THE
AGENCY UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF
OTHERS.
AND IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
DIRECTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AT THE TIME.
>> Laura: AND THAT WAS THAT.
MOVE ON.
WHILE, IT WASN'T UNTIL DECEMBER
OF 2014 WHEN THE SENATE INTEL
COMMITTEE RELEASED A REPORT
SEVERELY CRITICIZING ENHANCED
INTERROGATION, DESCRIBING THE
TECHNIQUES AS TORTURE, WHICH
YIELDED LITTLE INTELLIGENCE.
THAT ANYONE BEGAN TO REALLY CARE
THAT MUCH ABOUT IT.
DURING A PRESS CONFERENCE AT CA
DIRECTOR, SP 24 SUDDENLY
REVERSED COURSE, DEFENDED THE
PROGRAM, AND REFUSED TO LABEL
TECHNIQUES LIKE
WATERBOARDING TORTURE.
EVEN THE MEDIA SEEMED A LITTLE
BIT SYNTHETIC.
NBC'S ANDREA MITCHELL, SHE
LOBBED THIS SOFT BALL AT THE CA
DIRECTOR.
>> DO YOU THINK THE BIN LADEN
CASE CAN BE ATTRIBUTED IN SOME
PART TO ENHANCED INTERROGATION
TECHNIQUES OR TORTURE?
>> THE DETAINEES WHO WERE
SUBJECTED TO ENHANCED
INTERROGATION TECHNIQUES
PROVIDED INFORMATION THAT WAS
USEFUL AND WAS USED IN THE
ULTIMATE OPERATION TO GO AGAINST
BIN LADEN.
>> Laura: WELL, NOT ONLY DID
HE GO ON THE RECORD DEFENDING
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION'S
AGGRESSIVE INTERROGATION
TACTICS, HE ALSO REPORTEDLY
OBJECTED TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S DECISION TO
RELEASE THE BUSH INTERROGATION
MEMOS AND OTHER RELATED
DOCUMENTS.
APPARENTLY HE DID THINK THE
PROGRAM HAVE VALUE, WHETHER OR
NOT IT ACTUALLY LED TO THE
ELIMINATION OF BIN LADEN, WHO
KNOWS.
BUT REMEMBER BRENNAN WAS THAT
CA'S DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WHEN ENHANCED INTERROGATION
TECHNIQUES WERE BEING USED.
AND HE STILL WAS CONFIRMED AS
CIA DIRECTOR BY DEMOCRATS.
BRENNAN WAS ALSO THE SUPERIOR TO
GINA HASPEL.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NOMINEE TO
BECOME CIA DIRECTOR.
>> WERE YOU INVOLVED IN ANY WAY
IN THE CREATION OF THE ENHANCED
INTERROGATION PROGRAM?
>> SENATOR, I WAS NOT, AND I WAS
NOT WRITING THE PROGRAM UNTIL
ABOUT A YEAR INTO ITS EXISTENCE.
>> Laura: AND GET TO LEARN
ABOUT THE ENHANCED INTERROGATION
AT ABOUT THE SAME TIME?
AS GINA HASPEL?
CONGRESS.
YES.
FAST FORWARD TO TODAY.
NANCY PELOSI AND HER FELLOW
DEMOCRATS WANT TO RAISE A BIG
FUSS AND PRETEND THAT THEY HOLD
THE MORAL HIGH GROUND AGAINST
TORTURE?
WHERE WERE HER OBJECTIONS OR ANY
OF THEIR OBJECTIONS WHEN THEY
WERE BEING BRIEFED ON THESE
TECHNIQUES?
INSTEAD, DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS LIKE McCAIN AND
PAUL ARE USING HASPEL'S
INVOLVEMENT IN THE PROGRAM TO
TRY TO BLOCK HER CONFIRMATION AS
CIA DIRECTOR.
BOY, WHAT A DIFFERENCE FOUR
YEARS MAKES.
>> MR. BRENNAN IS WITHOUT A
DOUBT QUALIFIED FOR THIS
POSITION.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH HIM REGULARLY CITE HIS WORK
ETHIC, HIS INTEGRITY, AND HIS
DETERMINATION.
JOHN BRENNAN, BY ALL ACCOUNTS,
WILL BE A STRONG LEADER.
>> WHILE MANY NOMINEES HAVE
CLASSIFIED BACKGROUNDS, YOU ARE
VERY UNIQUE.
WERE YOU AND ADVOCATE FOR
DESTROYING THE TAPES?
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF WHAT THOSE
TAPES CONTAINED?
DID YOU OVERSEE THE ENHANCED
INTERROGATION OF ALL MACHINERY
WHICH INCLUDED THE USE OF THE
WATERBOARDING AS PUBLICLY
REPORTED?
YES OR NO.
>> Laura: WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE FIRST ONE?
WHY DO THE DEMOCRATS WHO
SUPPORTED TO BE 24 NOW OPPOSE
GINA HASPEL?
WHAT CHANGED?
VERY CONFUSING.
I WILL TELL YOU WITH CHANGE.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOW PRESIDENT.
AND THE DEMOCRATS HE MUST BE
STOPPED AT ALL COSTS, AND HE BE
DENIED THE PERSONNEL TO HELP
ADVANCE HIS AGENDA.
IT'S NOT A TALE OF TWO
CONFIRMATIONS, IT'S A TALE OF
THE TWO FACES OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
ONE FACE THAT SUPPORTED ROBUST
NATIONAL SECURITY AND THE OTHER